and around for our speakers today go
ahead so let me traduce our panels we
have the filmmakers here on my right is
that doctor Professor Peter callison is
the Pellegrino University professor of
the history of sciences and physics at
Harvard University gala sins previous
film on the moral political debates over
the h-bomb ultimate weapon the h-bomb
dilemma in 2002 has been frequently has
been shown frequently on the history
channel is widely used in academic
courses in 1997 he was awarded the John
D and Catherine T MacArthur Foundation
fellowship and won a pfizer award for
image and logic as the best book of the
year in 1998 in all the way to the right
a professor Rob moss is a filmmaker and
professor and chair of the department of
visual and Environmental Studies at
Harvard University Moss is the same
river twice in 2003 premiered at the
Sundance Film Festival's nominated for
the 2004 Independent Spirit Award and
open theatrically at the Film Forum in
new york city and has numerous other
credits and then managing our
conversation today is assistant
professor bill Rankin whose research
focus on the relationship between
science and space and the territorial
scale of states of globalization down to
the scale of individual buildings and
he's very interested in the history and
intellectual impact of mapping so let's
welcome our panel again and and turn
over to bail thank
alright thank you Rick thanks Peter and
Rob for being here it's great so what I
want to do in our conversation here is
really to sort of focus on the film as a
form of scholarship as something that
rather than talking about learning more
about radiation hearing more about these
these historical events I want to talk
more about what it was like to make the
film the choices that you both faced
when think about was in the film was out
of the film and the kinds of the kind of
the hopes that you have for this kind of
work in your careers and other careers
going forward so one thing that I wanted
to start with very briefly I know he's
talking to you Peter that this is
something that you have been interested
in for 10 years or more so if you just
give us a quick story of where the film
came from and the very sort of
punctuation marks that went from you
know discovering the first document to
be interesting to you to bringing on
more people to making this a final film
well Rob and I have been collaborating
now for coming on 15 years we started
right after I made this film about the
moral political arguments over whether
physicists would build the hydrogen bomb
I went over to the the es department the
art department under another name and
asked to talk to the sum of the
filmmakers there and rob was one of them
and I said would any of you like to do a
course on filming science on that was
something that would combine looking at
history philosophy practices of science
in a way that would be filmer Boland and
organized around practice and not just
results or popularization and rob was
keen on it he dunst addition to the work
for which he is justly well known a
sequence of films about a group of his
friends and colleagues who were river
guides and I won't try to summarize all
that but they remark
films and he also had done some work
that intersected astronomy and so he was
interested in we started teaching a
course together starting in two thousand
and called filming science looking at
what documentary film is and what it
could be and how it might address
science in an exploratory way that was
not just popularization or dissemination
of previously obtained results so we
made this film together secrecy about
the national security secrecy system
that emerged out of the nuclear weapons
programs and governs at a very large
scale millions of people working with
classified status today and so we were
very interested in that this was before
the Snowden and Assange revelations and
it was something that we were was very
much on our minds and then I had done
this work that you mentioned about
thinking about nuclear waste and nuclear
territories we began to talk about some
of the strangeness of that problem how
out scale it was to the concerns that we
normally have in politics either in time
or spatial extent it kind of exceeded
our capacities so we started filming in
that and i'd say the big punctuation
point after that there are many other
things to say about the collaboration
the kind of visual styles that we've
chosen to work in maybe Rob can say
something about role of animation and
other things that we've been thinking
about a lot for over a decade now but
one of the big changes was Fukushima and
we started this film before the march
two thousand eleven triple disaster that
you all know about you see in the film
but once we saw that the once that
happened it became increasingly clear we
had to address it and that became a
fundamental transformation in the film
when we spent time filming as you saw in
Fukushima in almost exactly two years
after the accident and we were still
dealing with restricted parts of the
landscape
and people who were trying to eke out a
living in that area and how they cope
with it and that was really a
fundamental change in the design of the
film it was then that we really saw how
the film might function in its overview
great so I the question of animation i
think is really an interesting one and i
think i wanted to bring bring the
animation your discussion about what
kind of documentary this is because
obviously there's a certain level of
exposition here you have people
explaining things to us there are comp
concepts both technical and not so
technical that need that are being being
sort of we are being asked as an
audience to consider but then there are
lots of places throughout the film where
we're just asked to watch where there
are things that you know we may or may
not reach the same conclusions as you
the filmmaker our minds might wander so
there's a kind of tension between the
expository mode of documentary and the
kind of observational documentaries and
so I wonder if maybe Rob you want to
talk about it specifically how this
relates to other kinds of films how you
see the balance between the expository
the observational and then maybe after
that we can talk about the role that
animation plays there in particular but
first I just just to take a moment to
thank you all for coming to thank Yale
for inviting us Rick thank you he'll
thanks for being here also there's two
people in the audience who were in the
film who we learned a lot from whom we
couldn't have made the film without
their work and their inspiration that's
window bell and Ted Gordon just to brace
your hands right there were so pleased
that you're here and just can't go on
without acknowledging it before we
continue and hopefully can go to be part
of the conversation as well like there's
this moment I mean every film has a
relationship between exposition and
expressivity I mean it's just it's not
particular and I don't think documentary
is defined by exposition any more than
narrative fiction films are necessarily
and but they all have their own balance
that they have to achieve in their own
creating their own identity and that
certain things have to be made clear
before other things
can happen that's both true for
storytelling and for expositional kinds
of things and so I don't you know it's
like it's a it's a complicated thing I
mean just going back to where Peter
started about fukushima i mean the film
the origin of the film was really Ted
and Wendell's work I mean there was
something about that what being asked to
create scenarios for the future to warn
the future for up to ten thousand years
not to dig some place to make a specific
message to have created something that's
dangerous enough that didn't didn't
exist quite and then gets put in one
place and then you have to say we're
responsible to the future and if we are
then how do we warn people and how do we
think about that the kind of
mind-blowing pneus of this problem the
contending with this problem struck us
as a good starting point how to make a
film starting there what that would mean
and that led us to the waste isolation
pilot plant and to the idea of marking
the surface at some point when they
stopped putting stuff underground the
ideas that you put something on the few
in the surface that warns people and
that idea together seemed like well we
could film there that meant there was a
certain amount of exposition to get
through but it also seemed like maybe
that would be enough to make a film
those two things together the idea of
the present and the future turned out we
didn't quite have that exactly right we
thought maybe we needed to go to a place
where they were creating the nuclear
waste that was being shipped there and
that was the Savannah River Site in the
meantime Fukushima happened and it took
us another two years to get to Fukushima
we thought we could be done we could
have sort of where they're creating it
putting underground in the future which
would make a kind of stable narrative
triangle that turned out not to be the
case as well and once we went to
Fukushima there was something about all
these other sites are about trying to
keep things from leaking and trying to
protect the future and in Fukushima it
leaked so it was like the future had
visited us and once the future visited
us there was some narrative completion
that the wheel of the film could make a
revolution and sort of turn I'll stop
there because we have much to talk about
we can get also to the animation yeah
before we get to the animation I think
that I want to
this observation observational quality
of the film a bit more because I think
one of things that I was thinking about
when they're people talking are they
explaining what we're seeing or not and
often they are explaining overseeing and
then there are times when they aren't
explaining what we're seeing one of the
ones that really struck me as saying
that wasn't being explained was loss of
scenes of people just doing their jobs
so they're underground that got the
machines or they're running a truck or
they're inspecting the truck and we're
never really told what to think about
these things I'm wondering maybe both of
kind of from a filmic point of view but
but also from a scholarly point of view
what is the what is it that you're
trying to get at with all these really
kind of nicely slow paced scenes of
people just doing the everyday work of
getting the stuff done I mean there's
one I think that one of the things that
we've most been after both in the
secrecy film and here is this the
tension between urgent very material
very consequential sometimes political
not so much party political but deeply
political concerns and an imaginative
space of that these things occupied
secrecy is about urgent matters of
national security and it has
consequences and people's lives get
chewed up in this system one way or the
other with containment these are real
questions that have to be dealt with and
also it means something else in the
secrecy filament meant people were also
thinking about biblical or sexual
secrecy and it was really striking to us
that even these high officials from the
NSA and CIA interrogators and people who
are caught up in the system we're also
thinking about these other meanings and
here this idea of containment and
thinking about the very far future and
the role of imagination was for us the
concept the fact that these were tied to
something consequential and in the
immediate was crucial and those scenes
that are observational with people
working in a daily way with this place
unpacking it receiving these huge
Bannister's bringing out the 55-gallon
drums wrapped in this clear plastic hope
you know putting putting them into these
sections in the salt caverns people and
then Fukushima was even more so because
there was a way in which you know when
in some ways that whole sequence
culminates in the Prime Minister Naoto
khan saying you know that he thought he
we might lose modern Japan and you know
at that point this isn't just an
imaginative extension although it's also
an imaginative extension and I you know
I I think this this is a this is for us
really important that these scenarios
and the imagined monuments and the
monuments that were made hundreds of
years ago in Japan that are where we're
in their future and the problem of
legends and stories that occur in the
Nicky nuke scenario that that Wendell
had had sketched out but it's also about
something that really has to happen it's
a multi-billion dollar project it you
know eliminated shoot to hold up whole
towns from use for hundreds of years in
Japan that this matters so it's that
tension between mattering where you need
I think to stop talking and see be able
to pay attention if you're always wall
to wall words you sometimes can't see
what's in front of you like talking on
your cell phone and being not quite able
to read it even a sign above the highway
and but that happens in film too if it's
all talk and explaining and here's I'm
talking about a cow and you see a
picture of a cow and somehow the image
and the fabric and the material reality
vanishes so what are the other things I
think they want to respond to that
briefly as well which is the film has a
highly speculative tone and part of its
exploration is these things that are
sort of more philosophical perhaps if
those aren't grounded in something very
particular it just kind of will float
off into space and
I want to just cut a couple of very
small examples that I just you see a
film for a thousand times and you notice
things maybe you noticed and maybe not
there's a moment where allison
macfarlane is talking about the
half-life blutonium and its twenty four
thousand years and when she says 24,000
years it cuts to the woman who's
checking the truck to make sure it's
safe and it and it has this beautiful
rhythm it's like you know half-life
totem is 24,000 years from four thousand
one hundred years and there's a beat and
then the woman kicks the attire of the
truck and it goes thud and I just love
that it's like it's like this is safety
you know this is safety for 10,000 years
we're going to kick the tires of this
truck for 10,000 years and it's such a
wonderful human moment I mean this is
just her doing her job and doing a good
job of it I actually don't know why
people kick tired so it's like a 1930s
you know used car where you kick the
tires I guess you it meant something at
some point and now it's just like we
just do it and she's doing it I love
that moment there's a moment in the
middle when we're talking about you know
the far future and sending things to
outer space and you know Peter and I
just loved this notion that the closest
analogue to talking with our own species
10,000 years in the future was speaking
with aliens and that that meant that the
the teams had people who work for SETI
and that we thought that was really
interesting and then there's these
photographs and when I'm blocking on his
name said again no the one who not Dre
those oh sorry this is ridiculous no the
one who did the the architect who did
the designs mike brill thank you and
Mike grill is saying you know one of the
things is that moved him was that you
know one of the things that shows that
about this is that one of the things
we're thinking about in the future is
you you know you 10,000 years in the
future and then it cuts to a woman in a
supermarket who's this is like bunch of
grapes and she's just eaten one of the
grapes from the supermarket the camera
sees her and she sees the camera seeing
her having just eaten the
babe she's a little bit guilty she has a
kind of little half smile on her face
all this is communicated on this little
photograph that we're sending to outer
space for all time to say something
about what human beings are like and you
know there's something so beautiful and
simple and complicated about what
photography can do in these moments in
film and he's bits of observation
connected to these very bit big ideas
these tiny little incremental moments
and then finally mr. Sasaki as he turns
into his home two hundred times since he
was forced out of his home he turns on
his left turn signal didn't think think
think think it's like so wonderful it's
like who is he wanting but it's a kind
of habit of warning it's something about
human beings such moments go by you
don't even notice them really it's just
something about what films are like
something but non fiction can do it's an
answer to your question that's great I
their turn signal I was not only to the
left are also to the right I going to
just like that's great yeah so I
continued on this one of the things that
I would ever think about several sort of
ways that this is responding to a
certain conversation in the history of
science going back many decades to
questions of invisible technicians who's
actually doing the work of science to
more recent conversations about the
importance of infrastructure of
maintenance those kinds of things
obviously lots of work on different
forms of nucléaire ities days not just
the main nuclear bomb and because their
weapons reactors that kind of stuff but
nuclear activity all around the world as
I'm wondering if you could just say a
few words about how you feel like this
is responding to these ongoing textual
conversations about nuclear issues in
particular but also the sort of the work
of science I mean in a way are both with
secrecy and the first film I did on the
hydrogen bomb and and and this work I've
been concerned and we've been concerned
together with things that are invisible
invisible because they're classified
invisible because you can't look at them
without getting radiation poisoning or
invisible for different reasons and so
one of the motivations for looking at
think making things
visible and this brings up also
animation of different kinds that we use
in the film is is is that when things
become visible in a way they can enter
into our discussions in a way that
they're not otherwise accessible not
just pedagogically but a visceral sense
for scale and weight materiality and
what's involved with and to see that
these are real people shuttling the
stuff the half mile underground in this
salt cavern to see that they're people
that have to expect it and lower it down
an x-ray and all of this work is in a
way to to bring things into the
visibility and in to discuss ability
into our ability to engage with these
things as a society and so I think
that's very important there's also just
the in aesthetic or filmmaking aspect to
it that beyond just what people say to
see the work to see the material of this
stuff is very important and then the the
flip side of that of the animations so
one of the reasons that we wanted to use
the two were there many kinds of
animation but the two principal forms of
animation are the black and white fly
throughs and sort of three-dimensional
sketches that come from the drawings
mostly by Mike grill and his team these
are landscape architects and they had
the idea that you could design forms
that would communicate danger over and
above any specific communication of
particular bits of scientific
information or origin now there are also
mechanisms for trying to convey those
things the periodic table and what we
know about cancer and nuclear physics
and so on but these big forms were
supposed to convey you as my grill says
in the film you something's not right
here you don't want to be here and those
were those were taken from the drawings
that they had made and then we were
with David lobster excellent animator
who took those and then ripped off those
we had lots of discussions and we went
back and forth many times thinking about
different times of day and weather and
how to how to encounter that and then
the other form is uh is the graphic
novel something we've been experimenting
with in the previous film or was much
more extensive here and we wanted to do
those because rather than full-scale
full motion animation but because these
sketches of the future that Ted and
Wendell and others had had designed
we're really just like almost like log
wines or the briefest of Center istic
thinking you know in the legacy of
herman kahn and other other people in
war planning and wargaming you know a
bomb goes off at an air base in
frankfort we don't know who who dropped
it what happens next you know there
there's scenarios and not sense rather
than a script sense of scenario as the
French use it so we thought that if we
tried to make those into full-on
imagistic animation that had full motion
three-dimensional but otherwise I it
would violate the spirit of this what if
this flash in the dark what if that what
if the climate changed what if it was a
legend what if and that was what we were
what if a train penetrated the site what
if a robot lost its operating
instructions and so we thought that the
graphic novels were a better match for
that and would be less committing to a
style of how we imagine the future right
now the way the matrix looks like the
six months around the time it was made
instantly you know unless you're Kubrick
and the geniuses of the 20th century
most science fiction animation or
enactments just look like the time they
were made and we wanted something else
there was a little more
from that so that big Peter Cooper the
graphic novelist who worked with us on
those who spent we spent many many
months working on getting the style that
we wanted he had ideas we had ideas how
they should be broken apart reassembled
how that should work so trying to cap to
make a world out of all this was you
know was why this film took us almost
six years so the other type of kind of
non imagistic thing of course is the
maps and of course I I think about maps
for for my life and I wanted to see if
there something to say about the kinds
of narratives that the maps are offering
I have some thoughts about them but I
seeing then I think actually play a
really important role in kind of conquer
tising this and I wonder if either we
could think just talk about just briefly
about what that process was like I would
love to hear your interpretation let can
we start there I was like we hear
ourselves talk about the film all the
time and you had a thought about this
I'd love to hear it yeah sure so I think
there's a couple things one I was struck
by how they are maps of the present day
and they've emphasized the president is
by showing the particular roads and
urban areas and national boundaries that
we have today and so which I thought was
an interesting choice rather than trying
to show the world you know in the kind
of a historical mode of just mountains
and land cover and that kind of thing
and I hope that that was you know I
didn't know if that was a choice that
you had thought about that was one thing
was interesting the other day I was
thinking about was the the use of the
kind of the black and white in the
relief I think does to me a really great
job of showing this as a physical thing
you can touch landscape right these
aren't diagrams of political you know
pastel jigsaw puzzle shapes right these
are mountains and the social others I
saw this retention between this the the
present pneus of the cities and the
roads and the borders and the kind of
the rawness of this denuded almost sort
of Martian emptiness of the the
physicality of it I mean one of the
things is
the the I thank you that was wonderful
here what we have done we worked really
closely with Bobby petrushka am i
pronouncing his name properly a
wonderful artist he's an artist he's
also does a lot of graphics he does
sound installations he teaches of the
Graduate School of Design he was a
wonderful partner in helping us imagine
how the maps might be done we had had
kind of very wrote maps like as a kind
of stand-in for a long time and towards
the end of the films like no clearly
we've been meaning to get to this and
that we need to get to this and they do
different things I mean I think this
idea of having a landscape that has a
topography was important but there's
also some times where it's not just the
present it's the evolution of something
I mean when you see where the nuclear
power plants began you see the
timescales changing and the plants
growing kind of evolving over time that
seemed really important you can see when
that we were building them in a kind of
hurry when we slowed down how that's
what it plays it happens in a gesture a
visual gesture it doesn't stop
everything and announce something it's
part of the kind of ongoing this and it
has a kind of you can read it and
experience it as well as understand it
and whether it had to have all of those
things at play at once otherwise you
know maps like that can be the death of
cinema and we hope that it wasn't so I
agree that it has those things and they
mean different things when you cut back
to them because there are a visual
reference to something that you've seen
you understand a certain way and then it
changes each time he means something
slightly different each time and that
difference also keeps your interest
because you have to read it again it's
not like you're being told the same
thing again in the same way great so I
want to sort of switch gears a little
bit and talked about some of the major
choices that you're facing characters
that figure out what's in what's out how
do you get the people to do that are
going to tell this do this story for you
um and or how do you maybe choose
between seeing people as telling a story
for you and looking for primary sources
to understand what's actually going on
so one of the ones that to start with
there's no Chernobyl there's no Three
Mile Island
there's no nuclear mining in Africa
there's no you know weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq how do how do you
sort of decide it's just it is these two
things you talked about it briefly
before but how do you sort of have
either the restraint or the how do you
know when the got all the pieces and you
need no more pieces you know one of the
things that is very different at least
the way we think of film and the way we
think of written work is that in a
written work you could say there are
five major countries that are mining and
you know there's the central Canada
Australia Colorado Plateau in the United
States there's what when it began was
the Belgian Congo there's you know and
then that's fine that's these lists and
even typographically you know section
2.1 2.2 2.3 2.4 to you can see it a
glance what's going on in a film that
kind of encyclopedias 'um is just
unbearable it's tedious and you don't
want to see it and it's not what it's
not what films do well it's it's a you
can have a film with chapters they're
all sorts of crutches that can allow you
to imitate a written style but it's like
you know can you build a house without a
hammer again you probably could but why
would you do that and that's not what
hammers do that well and so with
Chernobyl we did have a piece in about
Chernobyl and we actually found some
pretty good archival material that we
liked about it but Fukushima was in our
immediate present we were able to film
people trying to cope in the immediate
aftermath of the of the event now doc on
was going to talk me we could we could
get at I mean it was hard for us neither
of us speak Japanese so him there were
challenges of filming in a radiation
zone in a language we don't know but but
but it was in our world and I think that
you know eventually we just decided
that's not we're going to leave out your
note that in a way Fukushima is going to
stand in for the loss of container and
we will go deeper into that
and it's true there there are books
about all the accidents that have
happened and there even a couple of
films to try to go through them all but
it doesn't you sacrifice the specificity
of what film can do of being able to
talk to the cattle handler in outside of
Fukushima and the young woman who's
trying to keep her house from falling
down and the rodents from taking over
and keeping a garden going and she
doesn't know if she's going to come back
and the older man who's living in this
place can't bear to leave it for more
than 48 hours but can't really live
there either and that's part of what we
want to do you would have to get rid of
that and then retreat to a report oriole
white paper which we didn't want you
know that so that was many many things
in the film or like you know hanford in
Washington state is another big weapons
laboratory very much doing the same job
as Savannah River Hanford has been
actually treated more often in the
literature and in films um and Savannah
River we also were just fascinated by
this ecological Wonderland that had the
highest density of biodiversity and yet
was the most contaminated site in the
continental United States so we made
choices like that Savannah River not any
of the 90 or so other sites not the
other weapons sites not Los Alamos not
Hanford not the places where the weapons
are assembled not Texas where the their
disassembled and so on so we made that
we had to choose and film you know one
of the things that's really striking in
a film if you take the words in a film
and you printed them out it's a couple
of the equivalent of a couple of pages
although we tend to think of a film is
analogous to a book it's not in terms of
words in other ways it creates its world
along other dimensions in visual and
sound auditory and sound design and
music and we can talk about some of
those other things but it's if you just
even if you chatter
the whole way through which would be
unbearable I it it's few words it's a 90
you know and so so I think that you have
to be enormously selective and
elliptical sometimes if you want to
elicit bring people into a world which
is our overriding ambition is to make
something where you can inhabit so I
think this gets to my next question this
was maybe he speaks to also brought up
questions about how the film was
actually made how you all collaborated
all the other army of people that we saw
their names at the end what are the
voices that were the hardest to find
either literally or you just thought
narrative Lee there was something
missing and you had to go find out what
that was that was missing how did you
find this amazing pastor in Georgia how
did you get the Prime Minister of Japan
former prime minister han to talk to you
but especially what are the what are the
ways what was the sort of the pieces
that really were the hardest to fall
into place in terms of just getting the
people together in the conversation well
I'm going to answer it in a slightly
different way which is what did we film
when we went to Japan I mean what did we
actually get that it's it's a we knew we
needed that but you know we were had to
figure out what to shoot from a very
long distance once we were there we're
filming in another language and it we
got all this material it's actually
quite amazing and most of it is not in
the movie and when we tried to make that
material play in a sort of complex way
give more voice tell told the stories
more in-depth to go into detail of what
it meant like all kinds of scenes that
aren't in then there was a way in which
it's a voice that had to enter the film
but if it entered too strongly it it was
like we were trafficking in an sort of
catastrophe a kind of catastrophe genre
and there was something unseemly about
it and it seemed to exceed what the film
needed and it took us a year of editing
to kind of find the right weight of the
Japanese material and what those
characters could do
how far we could go how it has a kind of
emotional but a lot of it is like like
stepped back so that you can it's just
gestures and a couple of things a few
things happen you know we're not sort of
pushing on it emotionally too much I
think that gave it a more emotional
residence I think more the story could
kind of creep into those images we had
you know it's a bit of an answer to your
question and it was really a question of
getting it and then cutting it back so
that it could live in the film and not
swamp the film and not suggest that we
were you know manipulating this footage
for the ends of the film and giving them
a kind of distance a little bit of
distance in a little bit of space so
that we weren't kind of you know making
hay over their misery you know I think
that I think it's totally right i mean i
think cutting back was really essential
and a lot of things that didn't work
started to work when there was less of
it but we filmed on boats but fishermen
we filmed in places where they were
testing fish we we felt we talked to
workers who were afraid of TEPCO would
find out they were talking to us sort of
meeting them in parking lots and and you
know they would tell us amazing stories
but we weren't trying to make a prono
nuclear versus anti-nuclear film we
didn't want the whole I mean I'd say
that that was one of our big goals from
pretty early on was instead of saying
okay here's pro here's anti we fall on
the side of anti are limited or what I
mean it wasn't trying to be that it was
trying to say in the world already
whether we like it or not this is the
legacy of more than half a century of
nuclear weapons and power production
what are we going to do it's an
obligatory problem with no simple answer
I
a comp began his critique of Pure Reason
by saying there's certain questions
which we can either answer more nor
avoid and that's kind of thing which we
can too we tend to be interested in
those in both in secrecy and here and
other things is you know what not
questions were like here's a real
problem and if you only sign a petition
or join a church group or you know
protest in this way or get your company
to do this then it'll be solved we don't
think it's like that we're choosing
among very difficult alternatives none
of which are perfect you know that we'd
probably end up thinking it's probably
better to bury this way stand to leave
it on the surface but as you can see it
sometimes it's leaks that's not great
but it's not like no one's giving it you
can't send it to the son you can't bury
it underground and in in the ocean you
can't you know they people want a magic
solution so I think we were trying to
sort of say if you're in the real world
that we live in where where we pushed
and were pushed to some pretty strange
places thinking about talking with
aliens and political Dominion the maps
were also there to show that extent that
this is doesn't obey national boundaries
and moves around unpredictably with the
wind and the water so it's we wanted to
inhabit this world and to see people
living among the waist which we all are
to a certain extent in what are we going
to do that so last question I have
before I we open it up kind of what
Tim's to me the most satisfying sort of
form of restraint that I saw in the film
we never figure out we never learn what
happened with this committee we never
know what the recommendations were we
never know what the marker system was or
is or will be and I actually don't want
you to tell me if there is an answer but
was that a difficult decision for you as
filmmakers to figure out how much of
that to close off on how much of that to
leave open and you sort of how do you
make a decision about how do you not
tell us the resolution of the central
material of the film well we have people
in the room who sort of know this in a
more intimate way than
it's an ongoing decision I mean the
waste isolation pilot plant isn't closed
they did come up with recommendations
but it's an evolving set of
recommendations you know there were lots
of scenarios about what might happen how
there might be inadvertent intrusion
into the way site not one of them
involved terrorism not that long ago
that was like at the top of the list I
mean the world changes and you know
materials change and what's possible and
how people are imagining this there'll
be some arbitrary moment in the future
when it has to be marked and they'll
have to figure that out and there is
something in place now about how they're
thinking about it but it's an evolving
thing and it seemed to put a lid on it
seemed to miss the point in a way I'm
trying to not to answer your question I
also wanted to come back to something
you said just being the end of this part
of the conversation but and just to pose
the question is can filmmaking be
scholarship I think that's a really
interesting question it's an open
question can filmmaking be scholarship
at a level beyond the topic of the film
in other words can films that don't have
topics that you can then talk about
what's nice is that you're not we're not
moving in that direction to talk about
the kind of content quite in the same
way but it would be easy to kind of move
this film into the idea of content and
then therefore scholarship and I think
that's a mistake I think that if you
don't engage the filmmaking if you don't
think about it in a much broader way if
it doesn't live as a film as well as a
topic then I think it can't possibly
even be considered scholarship it also
asks the question if it can be
scholarship is every film scholarship
them or if every meal by made by people
who teach in the Academy scholarship by
virtue of art you know I in these are
think live in interesting questions
Canada extended art forms besides film
like if you made an installation as that
scholarship could it be it's worth
thinking about it's like there's a new
director of the Harvard art museums and
one of the things we were talking about
is like could you make an exhibit that's
about art as scholarship or even just
exploring the question how do we even
begin to think about it I think thinking
about it is the first step in like and
not to assume the answers I think
to take this as a kind of serious and
open question that it's totally
fascinating and it's also like a great
opportunity there is something on the
other hand about people bringing their
disciplinary interests into the art
world that that's a fantastic
opportunity it's not that it has to be
you know I'm a filmmaker it doesn't have
to be a particular discipline but there
is an opportunity in the Academy when
people bring their disciplinary
expertise and then open it up to another
way of communicating that or engaging
with it in some kind of way and what's
revealed when you do that pretty
interesting great well I I definitely
continue talking about that but the next
20 minutes or so let's um let's have
questions from from all of you
alright thanks so much back to animation
for just a second um I have to know oh
sure I have to know more about Nikki
nuke or the Nikki new clan that was kind
of a in development and that actually
reminded me obviously of Disney and I
guess that's that's where my question is
coming from I was wondering I saw Disney
is definitely kind of linking both the
the content of your film but also
possibly the method as well so we saw
the links to you know Nikki new clan
definitely based on Mickey Mouse that
goes back to silent films with the
Steamboat Willie but also fantastic at
kind of conveying danger so we can think
of our villains we can think of the
dangerous places so I saw those links
but I wanted to ask about how Disney as
an animator might have shaped your
method of approaching the film I know
that there's also links to propaganda
and his health videos as well but
through using animation how did you see
him as a model I'd like that Wendell
would you would you like to talk a
little bit about the kinds of characters
you had in mind when you thought about
Nicky nuke I should say that I was a
member of team of four people and what
we came up with was not just my work but
Ted Gordon who headed the team and the
two other people on the team but I think
in the case of Mickey nuke we had smokey
bear in mind for years Smokey Bear
warned us about forest fires and I think
it's been through three generations now
Smokey Bear is still there at least for
us who grew up in the
west and Nicki knew I thought could be
like Smokey the Bear except his job
would be to warn us about where nuclear
waste is and I that was a gratuitous
scenario we were asked to by sandia
national labs to write scenarios that
resulted in releasing the radioactivity
but Ted my and others on our team we
thought we'd at least out one scenario
that showed that everything state as it
should be there was no radiation and it
was all because of the activity of Nikki
nuke telling us no don't go there don't
go there and I can imagine just like
Smokey the Bear Nikki new could become
something that we carried around in our
imaginations that could last for
generations how do you too honey one of
you said something about something about
point scenarios didn't use that term but
when we were instructed by sandia on
what they expected to see in the
scenario component they and they had an
overall design which we followed we
broke into four separate groups each
group took their own technique but
basically what people wrote was were
point scenarios I mean we had to focus
on something and each scenarios
different the tunnel between Houston and
Los Angeles was one of the scenarios
that we imagined a big boring machine
would would come along and be able to
make that tunnel and sure enough the
site was right in the middle of that
line that we drew but each of these was
a very poor indication of what the
future might be none of the scenarios
have high probability so inevitably we
ended by saying we missed the real point
the future is going to be different than
anything we created this is a good start
and maybe we
maybe we've circled circled it so that
if someone has this in mind when they
designed the warning system by luck it
will do warning in whatever world turns
out there really be the case now the
field of futures research has moved on
since then as you might imagine and now
not just point scenarios but hundreds of
thousands of scenarios expressed in
different ways and somewhere in that
panorama of possibilities done with big
machines obviously lies the real world
so we started having a better feel for
policy leading leading us to make
changes that move us in the direction
that we would find favorable today we
would ask the question how does the
world have to change in order for us to
avoid having this problem not what the
problem might be not what was the cause
of it but what should we be doing now
and in a strange twist of fate my recent
research has been in terrorism and I if
I had to do it over again I'd stress
that scenario look at look at what
what's out there waiting waiting to be
tapped and our inability to find those
who would who would do his damage so but
I do want to say guys great film good
job excellent nice felt and the part
you're part of it i found particularly
touching were those human parts the man
going back to his house but cowboy
touching the nose of the cow you know
this was his friend and he was going to
be sacrificed so good job thanks thank
you you know i'm one of the things that
I found fascinating is that in that
Nicky nuke scenario it seemed you know
wildly speculative you would have this
museum / entertainment center and it
would serve as a memorialization and
warning and in keV there's a museum
about the Chernobyl disaster that's
immensely popular it was until Ukraine
came apart at the seams
and was an international destination and
as a combination of entertainment and
instruction and there's talk about
building one in Fukushima that would be
a combination entertainment center
memorial in warning so in a way the
things that seem sort of most wildly out
there sometimes come to pass and in
terms of the models Wendell you once in
one of our many conversations about this
said that you also had in mind the
dilbert character who when you flew in
the in in the Navy at the end of World
War two would warn you about all the
stupid things that he would do that
would warn you to make sure you put down
your landing gear and I went and I dug
up all those old films so excited to
know them and you know that Dilbert
would forget to lower his landing gear
or he'd forget to secure his machine gun
and end up strafing the cafeteria and
his home base and he one disaster after
another and they were instructional so
then we found it so fascinating in the
Fukushima in the in the Japanese section
where we found this legend of called in
amor and oh hi this warning where this
storyboard storyteller would come to
each town and show you these sequence of
boards about the man who saved his town
in the 1850s in Japan by setting the
town's rice supply on fire and then
everybody came to put it out with
buckets of water and they were rescued
from the impending tsunami which he the
town leader was able to foretell because
he saw the tide going out in the wrong
way and and so a lot of these cross
connections between Japan the Japanese
story where we are in the future trying
to be warned by what was done 100 200
300 years ago and what we're trying to
do to warn our future seemed to us one
of the fascinating parts of intersection
hi so assuming for the moment that film
can be a form of scholarship and one
that you know as you said those
different things from a book it you know
might reach different audiences make
them think about issues in a different
way maybe the same can be said of like
popular books published with a trade
press or Jezebel articles are you know
podcasts whatever format you like how
can we make space for scholars to do
more of that kind of scholarship I mean
you know you said it took about the same
it took like six years like that's how
long it takes for the history book and I
don't think it's a coincidence that you
did this after you have tenure I am a
PhD student here I don't think I could
make this for my dissertation I got my
bachelor's from your department and I
tried to get permission to do like a
long-form journalism thesis and I
wouldn't let me because that wasn't
that's not scholarship scholarship is a
book that 10 people read so I'm
wondering if you could discuss a little
bit what I could do to find a way to
maybe make a different kind of
scholarship or what you all could do to
also make that option available to
people like me when I was an untenured
professor at Stanford is I didn't tell
my senior colleagues I was making a film
but did you have a time-turner like how
do you do but both things
surreptitiously did you sleep I'm I mean
I'm serious like I don't know it's just
like oh it's fine like just don't have
loved ones just make everything doesn't
seem feasible I don't want took 15 years
and I and I did it without telling
people but yeah no I think that the in
general you know one of the things that
I'm often comes up in my talk about this
in universities as people will say can
you do a film instead of a PhD thesis
and there are some places there are some
places to give PhDs in art I actually
would not recommend doing that i would
rather because i think so now on were
just at the professional advice
columnist here but I in placing students
I think it's been an enormous advantage
to students that have done some
filmmaking in addition to their written
work but if they have no written made
written work and they're trying to get a
job outside of an art department then
it's very difficult so I think that you
know it doesn't have to be a
feature-length film that you do it could
be in our course our students make
7-minute films and they're you know
there's no law that says that the only
kind of filmmaking is long form so it
may be that in the in in the process of
learning to add this to your quick
Newton out and they add this arrow to
your quiver it may be that it's that's
other short shorter forms of visual
exposition or auditory or audio
exposition or other kinds of development
may be better than trying to make
something that's always so I think that
the world is changing we used you know
we have a generation now several
generations who use visual sources in
ways that's one of the main ways that
they learn things whether it's looking
on YouTube for something or finding a
you know how they have a kind of access
to a world of not just of films but of
instruction of engagement of amateur you
know I iphone shots we have archives of
about Fukushima for example of tens of
thousands of tweets and archived iphone
images and movies it's a different world
of sources that allow different kinds of
work to be done in sociology and history
in anthropology and ethnography in
history of science and I think that but
we're still at a transitional moment I
think in I wouldn't like in good faith
recommend to somebody that they if you
want a job eventually depends why you're
doing your advanced degree but if you're
doing your advanced degree in order to
eventually teach in one of those kind of
departments I wouldn't think that it
would be good to forgo writing a thesis
but I think there are ways to deal with
the visual in ways that are tractable in
the real time allocation that you have
in the five years of graduate school or
whatever you spend doing
PhD yeah yeah it just could just briefly
there there is a peer oh as one of the
inventors of this and I'm on the
committee but there is a thing called
critical media practice it's what we
call a secondary field it's like a minor
for the graduate program in which
there's a series of courses and
importantly a capstone experience in
which you can make something in addition
to your writing but you get recognized
for this and you're part of a community
of makers thinking about things it's not
like the film version of your thesis but
there's some engagement with some some
visual aural work you can take some
courses you work with people you have an
advisor some extraordinary work has come
out of this really quite extraordinary
and it has helped people get work in
their fields because they've got this
extra thing and they have the work to
show it I don't know if yell does
anything like this I've been here other
times and this has been discussed it's a
wonderful opportunity for scholarship by
another name for a certain different
kind of scholarship to take place and to
be recognized for it so it's not 15
years covertly no life it's part of it
and it's quite wonderful 30 okay so um
very very interesting sobering but um I
was intrigued by the fact that perhaps
it was intentional that you guys do not
reveal a moral position on nuclear power
on nuclear energy how hard was it to
make the film without actually
addressing the question of whether this
is a way forward or not was that really
challenging or did it just it is I mean
there is a there are dozens of films
that are pro and anti nuclear power
nuclear power is the only thing is going
to save us from global warming nuclear's
is going to lead us to global
annihilation and nuclear winter and as
soon as you sort of start in that it's a
kind of you know swamp thing that mean
it takes over the whole film and so we
began we formulated a way of thinking
about this which is if you make if you
engage with nuclear power nuclear
weapons this is a problem that you will
have to resolve so and for those
countries like the United States
that have 50 60 years of this even if
you stopped and didn't produce another
watt of electricity and or another decal
on a nuclear bomb you would still have
to deal with tens of thousands of tons
of nuclear waste a million gallon tanks
177 of them in hanford and 50 of them in
in in Savannah River Site I means the
size of the Capitol dome upside down
filled with this highly radioactive
sludge and that's that's not going to go
well we hope it's not going to go
anywhere but it's not it we need to deal
with it it's it's a real threat it's
probably the biggest single radioactive
threat so we thought that in a way to
take it out of this name-calling
stone-throwing Pro anti-nuclear battle
and to say here's a problem that we have
other nations will have to if they
engage in this work and then Howard that
we need to think that along with the
nuclear that the back side of the
nuclear the distal side of nuclear
things has attracted much less attention
either in the broader cultural imaginary
where nuclear war is constantly there in
military circles constantly talking
about nuclear exchanges in city trading
and tactical nuclear weapons and smaller
lighter bigger weapons on that that in
historical terms political science
departments sociologists there lots and
lots of our scholarship is invested in
the multi-trillion dollar enterprise of
building nuclear weapons and nuclear
power plants but much less about what
this means for you know that no one
wants to talk about taking out the trash
at the end of the party it's the party
that interests people and and so we
wanted to we thought there was something
actually amazingly philosophically
morally politically interesting about
this stuff that is like is the distaff
side the back end of the steel cycle and
just quickly Prime Minister Khan feared
that one fuel pool one fuel pool
catching
fire might end Japan as he knew it he
experienced this as the Prime Minister
you know one barrel exploded underground
and the number is now it's like it
whipped and it's you know at the time we
finished the film the number was
conservatively at about three hundred
million dollars for the cleanup it's
still closed it's probably now at five
or six hundred million dollars one
barrel exploded and it exploded because
they mixed up the kitty litter because
somebody wrote down organic instead of
an inorganic it's like an organic as
opposed to inorganic and the organic
created this kind of bomb and it blew up
and that blowing up shut this place six
hundred million dollars later we don't
make a point of the film i would say
that well it's not like pro or con what
we didn't do and we worked hard not to
do was to press the sort of pedal of
fear too hard that everything nuclear
makes everybody so afraid and then once
you're afraid you're not really thinking
about anything we wanted people to
engage with the ideas and then you come
up with your own idea about the end of
it i mean we we think you should have
your own ideas about it but there are
things in the film that make nuclear
complicated and a little scary even
though we're not pressing the fear
button and that is where we we meant to
be restrained about that not so much
about a point of view but not
trafficking the fear in the same way we
weren't trafficking or trying not to in
the emotion and fukushima yeah thank you
it is a wonderful film and i think
actually it's ethically very rich and
complex by refusing to take that
position i just want to briefly bank a
small plug going back to the previous
discussion about scholarship and and PhD
students we have something that's maybe
a little more under the radar and not as
developed as you at Harvard but I do
teach a year-long course documentary
film workshop and this this year there's
been about 15 students in the course and
five of them are PhD students five or
master students in five our seniors
doing senior projects so that's a place
where particularly on the graduate level
is designed for students to do
documentary as a former scholarship it's
not a kind of escape from academic life
or a substitute for
for writing papers and dissertations but
it is a way of complimenting and so I
throw that out to people just to
continue the plug there's a new public
humanities program here there's an MA
there's work to make it a ph.d program
I'm the co acting co-chair of it and
documentary is one of the five fields
including digital humanities documentary
I can't I can't see what the other three
are right now but this is this is
graduate work for graduate degrees doing
this kind of project and doing it with
for under the auspices of public
humanities and it's also working with
the Smithsonian Institution so dig that
which was just announced I think in in
the paper so dig deeper if you want to
do this nobody's saying you can do it
instead of the text-based academic work
but nobody is seeing you can't do it
maybe as a way to one one more question
Johnny great hi thanks not no plug I was
curious about the sound in the
documentary and I was really struck I
mean the only time I've seen sort of
inside a salt mine of this kind is a
documentary called our daily bread a
german documentary which specifically
takes sort of no moral position on food
production but has no music in the
voice-over and i was curious about your
decisions to actually have a music and
be people talking in some way partly
because that mode of sort of explanation
or the hermeneutic problem that you're
dealing with seems to be in some sense
short-circuited by having people on hand
to sort of explain or to act as the kind
of the caption or the anchor let's say
to the scenes we're seeing and secondly
I wondered about the time of the
documentary because you know as we all
know if you take a minute silence or
something time seems to move very
differently from you know if you have
sort of idle talk or chatter or
something like this so I wondered what
the decisions were in terms of sort of
occupying the space and therefore the
time in there
the sort of hermeneutic problem through
the soundtrack of the film Thanks um so
we worked the sort of layers of sound
are some of it is observational sound I
mean just in present in these spaces and
as bill was saying before I mean
sometimes it's just we just let that
play and cut back on sound we do want to
raise certain philosophical issues about
consent and and understanding you know
some fairly abstract ideas like but ted
says in the dead gordon says in the film
about the purpose of these scenarios
what they they weren't aiming to to
replicate or to pre replicate an
actualized future but to give a kind of
boundary of possibilities that's doze
mom so some moments are about that
sometimes it's somebody in their
experience of you know like the woman
going back for the first time to the mrs
s of caller going back to her the
restaurant where she had spent this time
with her friends and opens it up and you
know stinks from the tuna that's rotting
in the refrigerator and so there's a mix
that those kind of sounds then there's
then there's a their sound design we
worked with a very enormously talented
sound designer call henderson and he
working on you know sometimes very small
things at least they seem small but
where they can be evocative in an
extraordinary way in sometimes it's
Kwazii realistic like the dirt being
pushed covering up the old boxes of
waste that was a silent film or that
sequence with silence and sometimes it's
much more abstract fragments of sound of
mechanical or or even tones and then
designing that in relationship with the
muse
we started out with we worked our main
composers mike einziger is a lead
guitarist and composer for Incubus and a
former student of mine I so he kindly
contributed some wonderful music to this
and then he got an a-minus he worked for
an a-minus I tries we could never
afforded him otherwise as you can
imagine but then there were two other
tristeza and for Charles other music we
we spent a lot of time cutting back the
music too you know we found oftentimes
at the points of emotional intensity
that it's better to have zero music and
that one of the things that I think
we've come to working together over a
law over now a long time is we know we
if you if you push if you try to
exaggerate an emotion by musically
orchestrating it it's less emotional
it's actually just pisses you off at
least it pisses us off so I think that
learning to figure out what those
moments are where the music can carry
something or like in outer space my kind
secures piece that goes with the Voyager
spacecraft heading off into infinity
that was a place where we felt the music
did a lot whereas if you tried to put it
underneath Prime Minister Khan speaking
about potentially losing Japan it was
catastrophic I mean it didn't it made it
week so and then the music and the sound
design have to go together and that and
the found sound so I mean they're the
experiential sound so you have these
layers of sound and oh there's a
tremendous amount of work getting these
very small things butts out a tiny bit
of sound can give you a feeling of
volume just spatial volume or extent a
small in in amazing ways it's actually
astonishing I think constantly
astonishing to us how much a small sound
change shifted the affective and
cognitive content of a scene
okay with that my own quasi plug
responsive chelsea's thing I think that
one of the ways to make the scholarship
really stick is to have these kind of
conversations develop a vocabulary to
have a public conversation about them I
think this is a great one so thank you
all for being part of it I think Peter
and Robbie